et pour ce qui est contre la science
helvète
la séance est levée la séance est levée
[Musique]
bonjour je suis à bruno bonnell je suis
le député de la 6e circonscription du
rhône nous sommes ici à villeurbanne
villeurbanne fait partie de la la
métropole de lyon un des endroits les
plus touchés par cette deuxième vague et
j'ai choisi de vous emmener en en
priorité aux médipôle le plus grand
hôpital privé d'europe dans lequel on va
essayer de voir là la réalité de ce
colis la circonscription de bruno
bonnell correspond exactement à la
commune de villeurbanne un territoire en
état d' alerte maximale
le rhône et le département de france qui
compte le plus d'hospitalisations
coronavirus le député veut mettre une
réalité humaine
derrière les chiffres et les classements
il entre au coeur du réacteur
la ligne de front de l'hôpital là où se
jouent les vies
le service de réanimation
mais un but mais aubin
d'accord pour monter un taux naturel
ce service vient de passer de 20 à 30 de
lits mais la deuxième vague qui se
présente menace de le submerger
complètement
on a vraiment des chiffres qui donnent
très préoccupant depuis je dirais une
dizaine de jours et ça veut dire combien
peu près par jour qui qui vous intégrer
dans les cinq grosses et c'est en gros 3
4 entrées par jour
ah oui devrait passer un par mois à 3 4
jours exactement c'est dans ces deux
stands ampleur-là on a clairement peur
d'être à saturation donc c'est la
saturation pour parler d'une situation
concrète c'est un patient qui en
situation de détresse respiratoire et
qu'on ne peut pas cueillir dans un lit
de réanimation sur l'établissement parce
qu'il y en a plus et qu' il y en a plus
non plus dans l'agglomération donc c'est
vraiment ça nos craintes
une crainte partagée par tout le
personnel et notamment celles qui se
retrouvent à nouveau en première ligne
les infirmières on a un peu le sentiment
que la deuxième vague est encore plus
intense les patients sont très grave y
reste très longtemps on a bossé et j'ai
entendu un médecin pas ici un qui disait
qu'il n'avait jamais vue dans le service
de réa autant de décès rapprocher oui
oui nous c'est un truc ça nous a choqués
at ease c'est
la semaine dernière ça a été
particulièrement éprouvant pour nous ce
qu'on a
on a perdu 7 8 malades en très peu de
temps et donc mais pour nous c'est assez
psychologiquement pas toujours facile
heureusement n'a des psychologues sont
là on en discute beaucoup entre nous on
débrief des situations un peu compliqué
voilà les plus anciens sont là pour
aider les plus jeunes tout ça on a pris
la première vague donc ça c'est un vrai
plus pour l'équipe parce que du coup il
ya une sérénité quand même malgré tout
on sait que le travail va être difficile
quand on va aller sur voilà sur internet
quand même plus ou moins lourd qu'il
faut tenir et te dirai moins difficile
quand on se sent valorisé après la
première vague les infirmières du privé
ont obtenu d'augmentation 160 euros net
par mois
il ya eu une revalorisation salariale il
ya eu un travail qui a été fait et c'est
déjà quelque chose de très positif pour
nous que le solaire madame d'une machine
est en réanimation alors en début de
carrière
c'est aux alentours de 1500 euros mais
500 en 1550 euros alternance jour nuit à
peu près un week-end sur deux
moi qui suis à bientôt neuf ans
d'expérience
je suis aux alentours de 2000 euros
évidemment il y en a c'est jamais
suffisant maintenant on pouvait vous
promettre que demain ça sera ça sera
3,25 et que ça va être génial c'est pas
raisonnable parce que il faut alors
trouver les équilibres
mais le soutien ne se compte pas quand
chiffres les soignants attendent aussi
une vraie prise de conscience de
l'urgence sanitaire par la population ce
médecin confie aux députés ses
préoccupations pour lui les français
semblent plus réticents à sacrifier leur
quotidien nous on s'attend vraiment à
vivre quelque chose d'historique dans
nos histoires de réanimation dans nos
services avec des patients qu'on ne
saura très très clair plus très bien où
m et on sent qu'à côté de ça et encore
des discussions qui nous paraissent un
peu un peu étonnante l'engagement de
sauver des vies il y prime sur tous les
autres ya pas une bar mitzvah ya pas un
mariage
il n'y a pas une fête entre amis qui me
vaut une vie humaine
y'a pas un bar qui me nuit magna pas un
restaurant
la réalité de cette maladie le député
lacaunais contaminé trois semaines plus
tôt il est resté dijon au lit pas de
complications graves mais bruno bonnell
est convaincu d'une chose ils auraient
pu se retrouver lui aussi à l'hôpital
bonjour monsieur ce virus touche aussi
les personnes moins âgés et cela se
vérifie avec le dernier patient arrivé
aux urgences
je vais maintenant respirer et là
j'avais deux en appartement d'habitude
au cinquième étage on n'a pas de
l'ascenseur je m'entends courant vous
imaginez que j'arrive dans monte marche
par marche les choses j'ai dû m'arrêter
à chaque étage et certaines choses qu'on
découvre donc on en saurait à travers la
télévision votre attention
il ya la maladie tout ça mais quand vous
êtes donc ceci autres choses les choses
ne vont pas de la mutation balle au
visage à faire passer c'est de
sensibiliser le plus de monde par cette
maladie et les pas facile
et dieu sait qu'il n'est pas facile le
problème qui est que les gens s'en
rendent même pas compte et certains la
jeunesse une jeunesse inconsciente un
respect insuffisant du confinement et
des gestes barrières
[Musique]
le député replonge dans un autre monde
à deux pas des salles de réanimation
c'est un énorme décalage parce que entre
ses visions quasi apocalyptique de gens
qui sont quand même entre la vie et la
mort et l'insouciance de certaines
personnes à ne pas mettre le masque à ne
pas respecter le confinement
on a l'impression que c'est une journée
ordinaire comment est-ce que vous je
crois qu'il ya un déni sanitaire
aujourd'hui cette deuxième vague elle
n'est pas rentrée dans l'inconscient
collectif
on a beau marteler les chiffres les
chiffres finalement fatigue les gens moi
j'ai entendu des médecins nous dire mais
si les gens jouer le jeu on casserait la
vague on les écoute pas et on continue à
dire finalement le colloque ovine c'est
pas pour moi
la commune ne passera pas par moi s'il a
commis dell peut passer par tout le
monde et notamment on peut la passer à
tout le monde et ça je pense qu'il n'ya
pas du tout de conscience là dessus et
la responsabilité individuelle est
véritablement en jeu donc c'est l'échec
de la responsabilité à des vidéos
bruno bonnell est en colère une chose
quand même peut le rassurer
à villeurbanne les commerçants du centre
ville respecte le confinement pas de
fronde ici seules les boutiques
autorisés sont ouvertes
la loi est respectée même si elle prend
parfois des allures de casse-tête dans
cette droguerie la gérante ne sait pas
vraiment ce qu'elle peut vendre pas
[Musique]
restons dans l'esprit de la loi
vous vous avez dans la catégorie de
votre de votre magasin le droit de
vendre jauger ce que ce qui vous paraît
essentiel n'est pas essentiel histoire
de pas créé les tensions qu'on a vu
après c'est difficile de discerner un
produit est ce qu'il est essentiel que
les pas essentiel tout à l'heure j'ai
dans le cash t&d vers mesures comme par
la crise et parce que c'est essentiel
ballan l'idée que c'est que ce dont on
peut se passer pendant les quatre
semaines ou des six semaines qui
viennent
défini l'essentiel est en fait la
logique c'est de se dire est ce qu
effectivement j'ai besoin aujourd'hui
d'un verre mesureur absolument ou pas
c'est un jeu c'est quelque chose
d'individuel mais a priori on peut s'en
passer
dans un coin de la boutique le député a
repéré un espace réservé aux jouets le
débat je veux montrer là ce que je
voulais vous montrer
il s'improvise chef de rayon voyez là
l'impression qu'on a en fait quand on
rentre c'est vous êtes un peu comme deux
magasins donc toute cette partie
droguerie épicerie je reviens pas sur ce
que j'ai dit c'est totalement légal là
par contre si vous pouviez fermer ici
jusqu'à là c'est à dire effectivement
isolé ça empêche pas la puériculture ça
empêche pas tout ça mais cette partie là
normalement devrait être accessible
qu'en click and collect je le comprends
je comprends aussi la réaction de
certains collègues qui ils sont fermées
en commerce de proximité on est quand
même on fait vraiment respecté les
gestes barrière
le problème c'est pas votre magasin le
problème c'est l'ensemble des gens qui
circulent dans une rue si les commerces
restent ouverts
le problème c'est que là le croisement
de tous ces gens là personne qui va
fumer sa cigarette dans la rue donc il a
baissé son masque et qui par hasard vous
allez croiser à ce moment là donc je
pense que l'idée c'est de ralentir
physiquement la circulation des gens
comme bien des
avant d'être député bruno bonnell a été
patrons de grandes entreprise
d'informatique de robotique
il veut croire que malgré le confinement
le commerce peut se développer même
quand la vitrine est fermé à bonjour
bonsoir monsieur je me glisse dans cette
boutique de jeux les clients peuvent
acheter en ligne et retirer en magasin
vous avez click and collect tout à fait
se serait mis en place pour garder une
visibilité puis un semblant d'activité
ouais et la réaction des gens la
réaction est très positif le député voit
dans ce nouveau fonctionnement une
opportunité de développer les affaires
reste à en convaincre le commerçant est
ce que vous êtes au courant que les
banques notamment la bpi ont un prêt
spécifique pour les commerçants sur le
click and collect sur le click and
collect nom personnel je me suis passe
le spécifiquement renseigner parce que
j'ai pas prévu non plus de de développer
ses activités cette activité qui est
pour moi une activité systèmes d d'enfin
qui doit être ponctuel vu qu'elle ne
correspond pas à mes choix travail aussi
pourtant vendre en ligne en plus du
magasin c'est le sens de l'histoire
pour google
c'est un filet de sécurité si jamais on
avait d'autres crises j'essaye de dire
là dedans comment on peut trouver des
solutions pour faire évoluer ses métiers
pour qu'ils soient pas toujours
dépendant de ces confinement au
confinement qui risque de devenir un
quotidien régulier des années à venir et
non pas simplement des semaines à venir
expliquer le confinement le rendre
acceptable c'est la difficile mission d'
un député de la majorité dans sa
circonscription
en attendant des jours meilleurs